This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In the late 1960s, an Italian industrialist and a Scottish scientist started a club to address what they considered to be humankind's greatest problems, things like pollution, resource scarcity, and overpopulation. And because this group met in Rome, Italy, it came to be known as the Club of Rome. Producer Katie Mingle. Over the next couple of years, the Club of Rome would grow to include politicians, scientists, economists, and business leaders from around the world.
这里是“99%无形”（99% Invisible）。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。在20世纪60年代末，一位意大利实业家和一位苏格兰科学家发起了一个俱乐部，旨在解决他们认为的全人类最严重的问题，比如污染、资源匮乏和人口过剩。由于这个小组成员在意大利罗马开会，它后来被称为“罗马俱乐部”（Club of Rome）。本集节目由制片人凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）制作。在接下来的几年里，罗马俱乐部不断发展壮大，吸引了来自世界各地的政治家、科学家、经济学家和商界领袖。
It was a pretty elite group. I've always pictured a lot of leather, furniture, and cigar smoking. I don't know how much cigar smoking there was. I mean, it was certainly clubby. That's Patrick McCray. He's a professor of history at the University of California, Santa Barbara. I think there certainly was a tendency to imagine them as sort of this cigar smoking cabal,
这是一个相当精英的群体。我脑海中总是浮现出大量的皮革、家具和雪茄烟雾。我不知道当时抽雪茄的有多少。我的意思是，它确实很有俱乐部的派头。说话的是帕特里克·麦克雷（Patrick McCray）。他是加利福尼亚大学圣巴巴拉分校的历史学教授。我认为，人们肯定倾向于把他们想象成那种抽着雪茄的幕后小集团，
sort of pulling the strings behind the scenes, but I think there was a genuine interest on their part to address these problems of the world. The people who were a part of the club of Rome basically wanted to figure out if and when the world was going to hit maximum capacity in one out of resources, and toward this end they had a tool, a relatively new tool at the time, the computer. And so they plugged a bunch of data into their huge 1970s computers. And then looked at the results and switched up the variables and ran the tests again. No matter how they played with the variables, which were resource use, pollution, industrialization,
仿佛在幕后操控一切，但我认为他们确实出于真诚的兴趣来解决这些世界问题。罗马俱乐部的那群人基本上是想弄清楚，世界是否以及何时会达到最大承载能力并耗尽资源。为了这个目的，他们拥有一个工具，一个当时相对较新的工具——计算机。于是，他们把一堆数据输入到他们那台20世纪70年代的大型计算机中，然后查看结果，改变变量，再次运行测试。无论他们如何调整变量——包括资源使用、污染、工业化、
population growth, things like that. All of the models that they came up with, all of them sort of led to the same conclusion. Sometime in the 21st century, there would be this massive collapse of global society. In 1972, the Club of Rome published a book outlining their findings called The Limits to Growth, and it got a lot of media attention. They found the way things are going now, the planet can support us for less than 100 years.
人口增长诸如此类的事情——他们得出的所有模型，无一例外都指向了同一个结论：在21世纪的某个时候，全球社会将面临大规模崩溃。1972年，罗马俱乐部出版了一本概述他们研究成果的书，名为《增长的极限》（The Limits to Growth），这引起了极大的媒体关注。他们发现，按照目前的趋势发展下去，地球支撑人类的时间将不足100年。
It may be nearer 50. The book became a surprise bestseller and was translated into more than two dozen languages. And yeah, there were critics who disagreed with the findings, but overall, the limits to growth was incredibly influential. You know, there was a famous cover of Newsweek around 1973 that shows Uncle Sam on the cover looking into a cornucopia, and there's nothing in it, and the headline on the cover of Newsweek says, running out of everything. You can see the idea of limits all over popular culture. New York City in the year 2022. Nothing runs anymore. Nothing works.
甚至可能接近50年。这本书意外成为畅销书，并被翻译成二十多种语言。是的，确实有批评者不同意这些研究结果，但总体而言，《增长的极限》极具影响力。你知道，1973年前后《新闻周刊》（Newsweek）有一期著名的封面，上面画着山姆大叔正看着一个丰饶角，里面却空空如也，而《新闻周刊》的封面标题写着：“万物告罄”（Running out of everything）。你可以在整个流行文化中看到这种“极限”的概念：2022年的纽约市，什么都无法运转了，什么都不起作用了。
The famous or infamous movie with Charles and Heston, a soil in Green, you mean the whole premise of the movie is based on a scenario where there's overpopulation and the earth has exceeded its caring capacity. But the people are the same, and the people will do anything to get what they need. This is the police! What they need most is silent greed. The fire of silent green has been exhausted. It's a very dirty room. that green has been exhausted. We're going to return to your home.
那部由查尔斯·赫斯顿（Charlton Heston）主演的著名或“声名狼藉”的电影《超世纪谍杀案》（Soylent Green），你是说这部电影的整个前提都是基于人口过剩且地球已经超出其承载能力的假设。但人还是那些人，人们会不择手段地去获取他们需要的东西。这是警察！他们最需要的是“绿藻营养块”（Soylent Green）。绿藻营养块的供应已经耗尽了。这是一个非常脏乱的房间……绿藻营养块已经耗尽了。我们要送你回家。
But I think there was this really fierce debate that the limits to growth report stimulated about whether there was this need to curtail economic growth and to regulate populations and perhaps even curtail individual freedoms. And out of this chorus of debate and alarm emerges a physicist and engineer named Gerard O'Neill. He was mostly known as Jerry.
但我认为，《增长的极限》这份报告引发了一场非常激烈的辩论，争论焦点在于是否有必要限制经济增长、调控人口，甚至可能限制个人自由。正是在这片辩论与警示的合唱中，一位名叫杰拉德·奥尼尔（Gerard O'Neill）的物理学家兼工程师崭露头角。大家通常叫他杰里（Jerry）。
And Jerry O'Neill says, yeah, we may live on a limited planet, but we live in a limitless universe. And the answer to a lot of our problems here on Earth may actually be out in space, in what O'Neill called the High Frontier. Here's Jerry O'Neill in an archival recording from the 70s. Opening the High Frontier means making possible and ensuring the survival of the human race. Jerry O'Neill wanted to build settlements in space. If you truly love this planet, the best thing you can do for it
杰里·奥尼尔表示：是的，我们可能生活在一个有限的星球上，但我们生活在一个无限的宇宙中。我们地球上许多问题的答案，实际上可能在外太空，也就是奥尼尔所说的“高边疆”（High Frontier）。这里是杰里·奥尼尔在70年代档案录音中的声音：“开拓高边疆意味着使人类种族的生存成为可能并得到保障。”杰里·奥尼尔想要在太空中建立定居点。“如果你真心热爱这个星球，你能为它做的最好的一件事，
is to move as much industry and as many people as possible from its surface out into space. O'Neill was motivated and really saw his ideas as a form of environmentalism. Gerry O'Neill wasn't the first person to imagine human habitats in space, but unlike others who had come before him, O'Neill was the first to crunch all the numbers and come up with technologically feasible designs.
就是把尽可能多的工业和人口从它的表面转移到太空中去。”奥尼尔的动机源于此，并真正将自己的想法视作一种环保主义的形式。杰里·奥尼尔并不是第一个设想人类太空栖息地的人，但与前人不同的是，奥尼尔是第一个计算出所有数据并提出技术上可行设计的人。
Over the course of his work, he would turn skeptics into true believers, fun support from NASA, and start a social movement toward the goal of building human colonies in space. Before he started thinking about space colonies, Jerry O'Neill was a professor in Princeton's physics department, but he wasn't content analyzing data. He liked building things. O'Neill's contribution to physics was re-engineering the way in which particle accelerators were designed and built. And he was really, really successful at this.
在他的研究过程中，他将怀疑论者变成了忠实的信徒，获得了美国国家航空航天局（NASA）的资金支持，并掀起了一场旨在实现人类太空殖民目标社会运动。在开始考虑太空殖民地之前，杰里·奥尼尔是普林斯顿大学物理系的教授，但他并不满足于分析数据。他喜欢建造东西。奥尼尔对物理学的贡献是重新设计了粒子加速器的设计和建造方式。而且他在这一领域取得了巨大成功。
He was very famous already as a physicist, long before he got interested in space colonists. So he was very much respected among his equals. And a person of great character, I always got along very well with him. That's Freeman Dyson. Yes, I'm Freeman Dyson. I'm a retired professor at the Institute for Advanced Study in Princeton. My subject was mathematics and physics. I was just a pencil pusher scribbling equations.
早在对太空殖民地产生兴趣之前，他作为一名物理学家就已经非常著名了。因此，他在同行中备受尊敬。“他是一个品格高尚的人，我总是和他相处得很好。”说话的是弗里曼·戴森（Freeman Dyson）。“是的，我是弗里曼·戴森。我是普林斯顿高等研究院的退休教授。我的专业是数学和物理。我不过是一个涂鸦方程的拿笔杆子的人。”
Dyson is being modest. He was and is a polymath and a veritable genius. He's made huge contributions in quantum mechanics, but also in nuclear energy, biology, and astrophysics. And he's got pop culture cred too. There's a video game character named after him. There's even a Star Trek episode about one of his concepts. Dyson was also a friend and colleague to Jerry O'Neill. O'Neill died in 1992.
戴森太谦虚了。他过去是、现在也是一位博学者和真正的天才。他在量子力学、核能、生物学和天体物理学领域都作出了巨大贡献。他甚至在流行文化界也颇具声誉：有一个电子游戏角色以他的名字命名，甚至有一集《星际迷航》（Star Trek）就是根据他的一个概念创作的。戴森也是杰里·奥尼尔的朋友和同事。奥尼尔于1992年逝世。
He had many students who were always following him around. He actually got his students doing real projects. It wasn't just talk. In 1969, the same year the first astronauts walked on the moon, O'Neill posed a question to his introductory physics students at Princeton. What makes more sense? Building human settlements on the surface of another planet, or building free floating settlements in outer space?
他有很多学生总是跟在他身后。他实际上让他的学生们去做真正的项目，这不仅仅是空谈。1969年，也就是第一批宇航员登上月球的同一年，奥尼尔向他在普林斯顿大学的物理学入门班学生提出了一个问题：哪种做法更有意义？是在另一颗行星表面建立人类定居点，还是在外太空建立自由漂浮的定居点？
Through months of research and calculations, O'Neill and his students came to the conclusion that building free floating habitats was the way to go. First of all, you don't have to overcome gravity every time you go on and off a free floating space settlement. But even more importantly, in space, you have access to the sun's energy 100% of the time. So no other sources of fuel would be needed. But when the semester ended, O'Neal didn't stop thinking about space colonization. In fact, he'd only just begun. It wasn't just dreams of some rather remote future. It was something O'Neal really thought
经过几个月的调研和计算，奥尼尔和他的学生们得出结论：建造自由漂浮的栖息地才是康庄大道。首先，你每次进出自由漂浮的太空定居点时，都不需要克服重力。但更重要的是，在太空中，你可以100%的时间利用太阳能，因此不需要任何其他燃料来源。然而，当学期结束时，奥尼尔并没有停止对太空殖民的思考。事实上，他才刚刚开始。这不仅仅是对某个遥远未来的梦想，而是奥尼尔真正认为
he could do. O'Neal decided he would build his settlements at a place in our solar system 250,000 miles from the Earth, called Lagrange or Lagrange.5. Lagrange points are places in space where objects stay put. They don't move around on orbits. And so these are the most convenient places if you want to have a fixed habitat. Objects stay put because at Lagrange.5 or L5, the gravity of the Sun and Earth are a special equilibrium. L5 was his favorite Lagrange point of place, which is the same distance
他能够做到的事情。奥尼尔决定将他的定居点建在我太阳系中距离地球25.万英里（约40万公里）的一个地方，被称为拉格朗日点（Lagrange）或L5点。拉格朗日点是太空中物体可以保持静止不动的地方，它们不会在轨道上四处移动。因此，如果你想拥有一个固定的栖息地，这些就是最便利的地点。物体之所以能保持静止，是因为在拉格朗日5号点（L5），太阳和地球的引力达到了一种特殊的平衡。L5是他最喜欢的拉格朗日点，这个地方到月球和地球的距离是相等的。
from the moon and the Earth. All of Oniel's designs for habitats were variations on cylinders, spheres, or ring shapes, and his designs have been copied all over science fiction. You can see O'Neill-esque designs in the movie's Elysium and Interstellar, for example. The design that I find the easiest picture basically looks like a giant bicycle wheel floating in space. The people would live inside the tire part of the wheel, which itself would be enormous. There would be huge windows that let in sunlight and allowed amazing views of outer space. The artist renderings of O'Neill settlements make them look really earth-like and appealing with water, trees, and terraced housing.
奥尼尔所有的栖息地设计都是圆柱体、球体或环形的变体，他的设计在科幻小说中被到处模仿。例如，你可以在电影《极乐空间》（Elysium）和《星际穿越》（Interstellar）中看到奥尼尔风格的设计。“我发现最容易想象的设计，基本上看起来就像一个漂浮在太空中的巨型自行车轮。人们将住在车轮的轮胎部分里面，而这个轮胎本身就会非常巨大。这里会有巨大的窗户，让阳光透进来，并能欣赏到太空中令人惊叹的景色。”艺术家对奥尼尔定居点的效果图让它们看起来非常像地球且极具吸引力，配有水、树木和梯田式住宅。
He imagined that, you know, it would be like an Italian hill town. We knew that the first ones wouldn't look like anything like that. That's Tasha O'Neal. In 1969, Tasha had just moved to the US from Germany to work as an O'Pare when she decided to attend a mixer, the YMCA, in-walked Gerry O'Neill with his mop top haircut, looking more like a member of a 60s rock band than a physicist. I looked at him and I thought, hmm, that's the first interesting guide that I see around here. I wouldn't say it was love at first sight, but it was definitely interest at first sight,
他想象着，你知道的，这就像一个意大利的山城。“我们知道，最早的那些建筑根本不会是那个样子的。”说话的是塔莎·奥尼尔（Tasha O'Neil）。1969年，塔莎刚从德国搬到美国做互惠生（Au Pair），当时她决定去参加一个基督教青年会（YMCA）的联谊活动。杰里·奥尼尔顶着一头拖把似的发型走了进来，与其说他像个物理学家，倒不如说他更像60年代摇滚乐队的成员。“我看着他，心想：‘嗯，这是我在附近见到的第一个有趣的家伙。’我不会说那是钟情，但绝对是一见倾心，
which grew into love very quickly. When he and Tasha met, O'Neil had just started seriously thinking about space colonies, and he was eager to share his ideas with her. I thought it was really ironic that I would meet and marry a physicist. My physics was non-existent, I flunked it, but he was so good at explaining things to lay people. And Tasha also got good at explaining his ideas. She explained to me, for example, that the wheel in which people would live
这份倾心很快演变成了爱。”当他和塔莎相遇时，奥尼尔才刚开始认真思考太空殖民地的问题，并渴望与她分享自己的想法。“我当时觉得很讽刺，自己居然会遇到并嫁给一位物理学家。我的物理知识为零，考试还不及格，但他非常擅长向门外汉解释事物。”塔莎也变得很擅长解释他的想法。“他向我解释过，例如，人们居住的车轮
would rotate very slowly on an axis. And the centrifugal force of that rotation would create a gravity-like sensation for the people inside to keep them from floating around. The rotating would have been very slow and you would not have noticed it. But the closer you were to the axis or the center of the wheel, the less gravity you'd experience. When you went uphill, you got lighter and lighter, and you started skipping like a mountain goat. You'd always say that. Gerry O'Neill imagined the first structure could house 10,000 people, and subsequent structures
会沿着一个轴非常缓慢地旋转。这种旋转产生的离心力会为里面的人创造一种类似重力的感觉，让他们不会飘浮起来。旋转的速度会非常慢，你甚至不会注意到它。但你离轴心或车轮中心越近，体验到的重力就越小。当你往高处走时，你会变得越来越轻，开始像山羊一样跳跃。”他总是这么说。杰里·奥尼尔设想第一个结构可以容纳1万人，而随后的结构
could house up to 3 million. He hoped that eventually these settlements could unburden the earth of a significant population. And O'Neill also thought his settlements could provide Earth with the source of energy by collecting the sun's energy in space, where it's in abundance all the time and sending it back to Earth via radio waves. This was a technology that another scientist had been working on already. By doing this, O'Neill believed... One has a solution to the energy problems of the world
最多可以容纳300万人。他希望最终这些定居点能够减轻地球沉重的人口负担。奥尼尔还认为，他的定居点可以通过在太空中收集始终丰沛的太阳能，并将其通过无线电波发回地球，从而为地球提供能源来源。这是另一位科学家已经在研究的技术。通过这样做，奥尼尔相信……人们就拥有了解决世界能源问题的方案。
At this point, you may be wondering how O'Neill planned to get all of the materials needed to build these massive structures into space He imagined the first loads would be taken by the space shuttle A new tool for which NASA had extremely optimistic plans Again, historian Patrick McCray a new tool for which NASA had extremely optimistic plans. Again, historian Patrick McCray. In the 1970s, people were predicting shuttle flights happening every week. And it was, you know, I mean, it was billed
此时，你可能在想，奥尼尔打算如何把建造这些宏大结构所需的所有材料运到太空中呢？他设想第一批货物将由航天飞机运载，这是NASA对其抱有极其乐观计划的新工具。再次请出历史学家帕特里克·麦克雷。这是一个NASA对其抱有极其乐观计划的新工具。再次请出历史学家帕特里克·麦克雷。“在20世纪70年代，人们预测航天飞机每周都会飞行。而且当时，你知道的，它基本上被吹捧为太空卡车。”
at the time as basically a space truck. But even with the space shuttle taking trips once a week, O'Neill knew that it wouldn't be enough. He'd need to get his building materials from the Moon. The Moon is a source of minerals, which we know about thanks to the Apollo project. All of the things, in fact, that we need for many of the products of an industrial civilization. So his idea was to move that material from the lunar surface using a type of electromagnetic catapult. This catapult was called a mass driver,
但即使航天飞机每周飞行一次，奥尼尔也知道这还远远不够。他需要从月球获取建筑材料。月球是矿产资源的来源，多亏了阿波罗计划，我们对此有了了解。事实上，我们建造工业文明的许多产品所需的所有东西，月球上都有。所以他的想法是使用一种电磁弹射器将这些材料从月球表面运走。这种弹射器被称为质量驱动器（mass driver），
and it would sling raw materials from the moon through space to the Grange.5. O'Neill and some colleagues actually designed a working model of one. The PBS program Nova recorded a demonstration of it. Three, two, one. Get up. All of the people who lived in the first-based settlement would be working in space as well,
它能将月球上的原材料通过太空弹射到拉格朗日5号点（L5）。奥尼尔和一些同事实际上设计了一个它的工作模型。PBS的节目《诺瓦》（Nova）记录了它的演示过程。“三，二，一。发射。”所有居住在第一座太空定居点的人也将同时在太空中工作，
to process the raw materials to build the next settlements. But there would also be jobs in other industries. I decided that I was going to be running the first restaurant up there, and thought about, you know, which spices I had to take along, that we couldn't grow up there right away. I mean, it captured the imagination. Not everyone was as enthusiastic about Gerry O'Neill's ideas as Tasha. By 1972, O'Neill had turned his ideas into a paper and was looking to be published in a scientific journal. He got a lot of rejection letters.
来加工原材料以建造下一座定居点。但其他行业也会有工作岗位。“我决定我要去那里经营第一家餐馆，并考虑了……你知道的，我得带上哪些我们无法立刻在那里种植的香料。我的意思是，这真的激发了人们的想象力。”并不是每个人都像塔莎那样对杰里·奥尼尔的想法充满热情。到1972年，奥尼尔已经把他的想法写成了一篇论文，并寻求在一份科学期刊上发表。他收到了许多退稿信。
But then in May of 1974, the New York Times ran a front page article about O'Neill's ideas, which changed our lives dramatically. We had to de-list our telephone number. Shortly thereafter O'Neill's ideas also found traction in the academic world when his paper was published in the journal Physics Today. And the requests for interviews and lectures and just came rolling in. O'Neill was interviewed by the Smithsonian and the Science Fiction Magazine Omni, even Penthouse.
但接着在1974年5月，《纽约时报》（The New York Times）在头版刊登了一篇关于奥尼尔想法的文章，这极大地改变了我们的生活。我们不得不取消电话号码的公开登记。此后不久，当他的论文发表在《今日物理》（Physics Today）杂志上时，奥尼尔的想法也在学术界获得了关注。采访和演讲的请求纷至沓来。奥尼尔接受了史密森尼学会（Smithsonian）和科幻杂志《全知》（Omni）的采访，甚至还上了《阁楼》（Penthouse）杂志。
And it was a very, very good article. I mean, I only read it for the articles. In addition to Penthouse, or maybe because of Penthouse, O'Neill even gained the interest of NASA, which funded a series of studies at the Ames Research Center. To explore all the different avenues and to try to find weaknesses in what he was suggesting
“而且那是一篇非常非常好的文章。我的意思是，我读它纯粹是为了看文章。”除了《Penthouse》杂志，或者也许正是因为《Penthouse》杂志，奥尼尔甚至引起了NASA的兴趣，NASA资助了艾姆斯研究中心（Ames Research Center）的一系列研究，旨在探索所有不同的途径，试图找出他所提议方案中的弱点，
and to really work out detailed designs that built on his original ideas. In all of his interviews and lectures, Gerry O'Neill talked about space in this whole new way. Space wasn't just a government program for elite astronauts to take part in. Space was a place, just another place for you and I to get to and explore. When we open up the high frontier by building colonies in space, there is going to be room for people who want to leave the earth to go out and to develop their own
并真正制定出基于他最初想法的详细设计。在所有的采访和演讲中，杰里·奥尼尔以一种全新方式谈论太空。太空不再只是精英宇航员参与的政府项目。太空是一个地方，只是另一个你和我都能够到达并探索的地方。当我们通过在太空中建立殖民地来开拓高边疆时，将会有空间留给那些想要离开地球、去外太空发展自己殖民地并做自己事情的人。
colonies and to do their own same. This idea of space as a place appealed to a lot of different kinds of people, and soon enough, a social movement started coalescing around O'Neill's ideas. By 1975, a group called the L5 Society for the Grange.5 had formed a spread-to-gospel of space colonization. They were very vocal, they were politically active, so they would oftentimes be lobbying, Congress or NASA for an expanded space exploration program, and they published a monthly newsletter. L-Fiveers were serious space activists, but it was the 70s, and there was a strange convergence happening of scientists, hippies, and beautiful nerds of every stripe, beautiful nerds with instruments.
这种将太空视为一个“地方”的想法吸引了许多不同类型的人，很快，一场围绕奥尼尔想法的社会运动开始凝聚成形。到1975年，一个名为“L5协会”（L5 Society，旨在支持拉格朗日5号点）的组织成立了，开始传播太空殖民的福音。他们非常直言不讳，政治上也十分活跃，因此他们经常向国会或NASA游说，要求扩大太空探索计划，他们还出版了一份月刊。“L5人”是坚定的太空活动家，但那毕竟是70年代，科学家、嬉皮士和各种各样的可爱极客之间发生了一种奇妙的融合——带着乐器的可爱极客们。
Alright, let's do a home on the Grains take up four. That's Bill Higgins. He's a physicist and former L. Fiverr who went to a lot of science fiction conventions in the 70s, where he says there was often a room full of people singing and playing instruments. Bill co-wrote the lyrics to a song that became somewhat of an anthem for the L5 society. The problem is solved, where the microwaves play, Down at three degrees K, and the cold virus never evolved. Home, home on the grain, where the space debris always collects.
“好吧，我们在Grains弹奏一首《家在西部》（Home on the Range），第四段。”说话的是比尔·希金斯（Bill Higgins）。他是一位物理学家，也是前“L5人”，在70年代参加过很多科幻大会。他说，那里经常聚满唱歌和演奏乐器的歌迷。比尔与人合词了一首歌，这首歌在某种程度上成了L5协会的会歌。“问题已解决，微波在弹奏，降至绝对零度三开尔文，感冒病毒从未进化。家，拉格朗日点上的家，太空垃圾总是在那汇聚。
We possess so it seems to of our greatest dreams, solar power, and zero G-Sex. I'm just going to give you a second to stop picturing zero G-Sex. Okay, for a while O'Neill seemed to welcome and encourage the attention from groups like L5. But the L5 society started to attract more controversial characters. With a showdowns, how many of you would like to live in space and live forever? How about it? Hey, there we go. That's incredible.
我们拥有它，似乎能实现我们最伟大的梦想：太阳能和零重力性爱。”我给你们一秒钟的时间停止脑补零重力性爱。好了，有一段时间，奥尼尔似乎对来自像L5这样的组织的关注表示欢迎和鼓励。但L5协会开始吸引更具争议的人物。“在进行对决时，你们有多少人想住在太空里并永远活下去？怎么样？嘿，我们来了。这太不可思议了。”
That's Timothy Leary promoting the idea of space colonization in the late 1970s. Leary became famous in the 60s for advocating the therapeutic use of LSD. And Leary had his own ideas about what space colonies could do for humanity. Rather trippy ideas about how building space colonies would help usher in this new phase of conscious human evolution. Having Leary as a spokesman may not have been ideal as O'Neill tried to get the government
那是蒂莫西·利里（Timothy Leary）在20世纪70年代末宣传太空殖民的想法。利里在60年代因倡导将LSD（麦角酸二乙酰胺）用于治疗而闻名。利里对太空殖民地能为人类做些什么有他自己的想法。关于建造太空殖民地将如何帮助引领人类意识进化新阶段的那些非常迷幻的想法。对于奥尼尔努力让政府认真对待他的想法而言，拥有利里作为代言人可能并不是最理想的。
to take his ideas seriously. You know, Leary is someone who President Nixon once called the most dangerous man in America. If you're successful in promoting and popularizing a particular technology or a particular technological future, you also risk losing control over the idea. You wanted to have the ideas out there. You know, people talking about it is better than not talking. People were certainly talking about it, and not all of it was positive. According to Patrick McCray,
要知道，利里曾被尼克松总统称为“美国最危险的人”。如果你成功推广和普及了一项特定的技术或特定的技术未来，你也面临着失去对这个想法控制权的风险。你本意是想让这些想法广为人知。你知道，人们讨论总比不讨论要好。人们确实在讨论，而且并非所有讨论都是正面的。根据帕特里克·麦克雷的说法，
many environmentalists of the time vehemently rejected the idea that space colonization could be a possible cure for our planet's problems. They saw nothing environmental about it. They saw this as an extension of the military industrial complex into space. And there were non-environmental critiques made as well. People said, well, okay, who's actually going to go into space? It's not going to be the urban poor. It's going to be basically creating these white suburbs
当时的许多环保主义者强烈反对太空殖民可以作为我们星球问题潜在解药的想法。他们从这上面看不到半点环保色彩。他们认为这是军工复合体向太空的延伸。此外也有非环保维度的批评声音。人们会说：“好吧，到底谁会去太空？去那里的可不是城市穷人。这基本上是在太空中建立白人郊区。”
in space. There was kind of a critique of some of Ineal's ideas as a form of literally white flight, I suppose. A rat done bit my sister Nell with whitey on the moon. Her face and arms began to swell and whitey's on the moon. I can't pay no doctor bills, but whiteies on the moon. Ten years from now, I'll be paying still while whiteies on the moon. You know, the man just stopped my red-labs night because whiteies on the moon. Gills got here and was just one of the people that voiced this criticism about inequality and the space race. But of all the critiques that were made of O'Neill's ideas,
当时有一种针对奥尼尔某些想法的批评，认为这简直可以说是某种形式的“白人群飞”（white flight）现象。“我妹妹内尔被老鼠咬了，而白人在月球上。她的脸和胳膊开始肿胀，而白人在月球上。我付不起医药费，但白人在月球上。十年后，我依然在付账单，而白人在月球上。你知道的，房东昨晚刚停了我的红外电灯，因为白人在月球上。”吉尔·斯科特-赫伦（Gil Scott-Heron）就是众多对这种不平等现象和太空竞赛提出批评的人之一。但在对奥尼尔想法的所有批评中，
no one really said this is technologically impossible. And in fact, in the 1970s, we had just put astronauts on the moon. Anything seemed possible. Patrick says to put this in perspective, he likes to imagine a hypothetical scenario. It's 1975, and you ask a random person on the street. Which is the more likely scenario?
没有人真正说过这在技术上是不可能的。事实上，在20世纪70年代，我们刚刚把宇航员送上月球。一切皆有可能。帕特里克说，为了客观地看待这一点，他喜欢想象一个假想的场景：时间是1975年，你问街上一个随机路人：哪种情况更有可能发生？
Scenario A? We are going to build a base on the moon and then we're going to build colonies and outer space. Or scenario B. We're not going to go back to the moon for another half century, at least. Now, I'd argue that in 1975, most people would have felt that scenario A was the much more likely one. In 1977, all of O'Neill's research was published in a very readable book called The High Frontier, and he appeared on 60 minutes with Dan Rather to talk about space colonization. Do you expect to set foot on one of these space habitats?
场景A？我们将在月球上建立基地，然后在外太空建立殖民地。或者场景B？在未来半个世纪里，至少在一段时间内，我们将不会重返月球。现在，我会认为在1975年，大多数人会觉得场景A是更有可能的那个。1977年，奥尼尔的所有研究成果都发表在了一本通俗易懂的书《高边疆》（The High Frontier）中，他甚至和丹·拉瑟（Dan Rather）一起出现在《60分钟》（60 Minutes）节目中谈论太空殖民。你期望踏上这些太空栖息地之一吗？
I sure hope so, Dan, or I wouldn't be working on it. That's your hope. What the question is, what is your expectation? I'm putting my own professional time and my effort into the scenario that says that these things will be realized within my working lifetime. But despite O'Neill's optimism, this 60-minute segment marked the peak of mainstream interest in his ideas, and the goal of building settlements in space began to seem less and less attainable. NASA's space shuttles did not become reliable space trucks. The shuttles ended up making far fewer flights into space than originally predicted.
我当然希望如此，丹，否则我就不会致力于此了。那是你的希望。问题是，你的期望是什么？我将自己的专业时间和精力投入到了这样一个情景中：这些事情将在我的职业生涯寿命之内实现。然而，尽管奥尼尔充满乐观，这期《60分钟》节目却标志着主流社会对其兴趣的顶峰，而在太空中建立定居点的目标开始显得越来越难以实现。NASA的航天飞机并没有成为可靠的太空卡车。航天飞机的太空飞行次数最终远低于最初的预测。
And in general, NASA became more cautious and less adventurous than a lot of people had hoped. Which is why in 1977, O'Neill founded the Nonprofit Space Studies Institute, which raises its own money and does its own research on space colonization. Gerard O'Neill died in 1992 after a long battle with leukemia. And now 25 years after his death, some people think that we're on the brink of another space age, one that could lead to the realization of some of O'Neill's dreams. There are a lot of people working on it. He had so many young people working with him.
总的来说，NASA变得比许多人所希望的更加谨慎、缺乏冒险精神。正因如此，奥尼尔在1977年创立了非营利组织“太空研究所”（Space Studies Institute），该机构自行筹集资金并开展关于太空殖民的研究。杰拉德·奥尼尔在与白血病长期搏斗后于1992年逝世。如今，在他逝世25年后，有些人认为我们正处于另一个太空时代的边缘，这个时代可能会实现奥尼尔的一些梦想。有很多人正在为此努力。他曾有那么多年轻人与他共事。
They're now calling themselves Jerry's kids and they're in their 50s, but they learned, you know, sitting at his knee, you know, Rick Tomlinson, Peter Diamandis. My mission in life since I was a kid was and is to take the rest of you into space. It's during our lifetime that we're going to take the people of earth and transition off permanently. That is Peter Diamandis giving a TED Talk in 2005. We've thought about the government always as the person taking us there,
他们现在自称为“杰里的孩子们”，虽然他们已经五十多岁了，但他们当年坐在他膝前学到了知识，比如里克·汤姆林森（Rick Tomlinson）、彼得·戴曼迪斯（Peter Diamandis）。“我从小的使命就是、并且现在依然是把你们其余的人带入太空。正是在我们这一代人的有生之年，我们要把地球上的人类带向太空并实现永久迁移。”这是彼得·戴曼迪斯在2005年发表的TED演讲。我们总是把政府视为带我们去那里的人，
but I put forward here the government is not going to get us there. The government is unable to take the risks required to open up this precious frontier. Like Gerry O'Neill, Diamandas believes that technology can solve humanity's biggest problems and that we don't have to live in a world of limits. But unlike O'Neill, Diamandis has another primary motivation. Money. The universe is full of valuable things to exploit for wealth. If you think about space, everything we hold of value on this planet, metals and minerals and real estate and energy is an infinite quantity of space.
但我要在此提出，政府是无法带我们到达那里的。政府没有能力承担开拓这片珍贵边疆所需的风险。和杰里·奥尼尔一样，戴曼迪斯相信技术可以解决人类最大的问题，我们不必生活在一个充满限制的世界里。但与奥尼尔不同的是，戴曼迪斯还有一个首要动机：金钱。宇宙中充满了可以开采以获取财富的有价值的东西。如果你想想太空，我们在这个星球上珍视的一切——金属、矿物、房地产和能源，在太空中都有着无限的数量。
In fact, the earth is a crumb in a supermarket filled with resources. There are other entrepreneurs like Elon Musk and Jeff Bezos who would also like to make money in space and build human settlements there. However, it happens. Both Freeman Dyson and Tasha O'Neill are sure humans will find their way into settlements in space eventually. Well, I would say it certainly will happen one day. It's all a question of when. And I'm counting on it because Jerry wanted his ashes to be
事实上，地球只是装满资源的超级市场里的一小块面包屑。还有其他企业家，比如埃隆·马斯克（Elon Musk）和杰夫·贝佐斯（Jeff Bezos），他们也想在太空中赚钱并在那里建立人类定居点。无论如何实现，弗里曼·戴森和塔莎·奥尼尔都坚信人类最终会找到进入太空定居的方法。“嗯，我要说的是，这有一天一定会发生。这全是个时间问题。”“而且我指望着它发生，因为杰里希望他的骨灰撒在太空殖民地里，我想现在，你知道的，他的孙辈们——或者我希望不是他的曾孙辈，但总会有人——必须去完成它。”
scattered in a space colony and I think by now, you know, his grandchildren will or I hope not his great grandchildren, but somebody will have to do it. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Katie Mingle, the Sam Green's fan-sharifuse chef Delaney Hall, Kurt Coles said Avery Trouffleman and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Robert Smith from the Space Studies Institute for all of his help on this story, and thanks to Carolyn Minnell for talking to us about the L5 Society and Bill Higgins for sharing his home on the grain song with us. To learn more about Gerardo Neal and his plans for colonizing space, check out Patrick McRae's book, The Visionears, how a group of elite scientists pursued space colonies, nanotechnologies,
《99%无形》本周由凯蒂·明格尔、萨姆·格林（Sam Greens）、范·沙里夫斯（Fan Sharifuse）、谢夫·德兰尼·霍尔（Chef Delaney Hall）、库尔特·科尔斯特（Kurt Colested）、埃弗里·特劳夫曼（Avery Truffleman）以及我罗曼·马尔斯共同制作。特别感谢太空研究所的罗伯特·史密斯（Robert Smith）对本期故事提供的所有帮助，感谢卡罗琳·米内尔（Carolyn Minnell）与我们畅谈L5协会，感谢比尔·希金斯与我们分享他的歌曲《家在格朗日点上》。想要了解更多关于杰拉德·奥尼尔及其太空殖民计划的信息，请查阅帕特里克·麦克雷的书《梦想家：精英科学家群体如何追求太空殖民地、纳米技术、
and a limitless future. Also be sure to check out the artist's renderings of the O'Neal settlements that NASA commissioned in the 70s. We have a few of those on our website at 99pi.org. This episode is part of PRX's Stories in Science projects, supported by the Alfred P. Sloan Foundation to enhance public understanding of science, technology, and economic performance, more at Sloan.org.
以及无限的未来》（The Visionears: How a Group of Elite Scientists Pursued Space Colonies, Nanotechnologies, and a Limitless Future）。同时，千万不要错过NASA在20世纪70年代委托制作的奥尼尔定居点艺术家效果图。我们的网站 99pi.org 上就展示了其中的几张。本集节目是PRX的“科学故事”项目的一部分，该项目由阿尔弗雷德·P·斯隆基金会（Alfred P. Sloan Foundation）资助，旨在增强公众对科学、技术和经济绩效的理解，详情请访问 Sloan.org。
We are a project of 91.7 KALW San Francisco and produced out of the offices of Arxine, who is actually looking for a couple new architects with 5 to 15 years experience in your CV to design at Arxine.com and you too can work in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook and follow us all on Twitter and Instagram. But the best way to explore the 99% invisible activity that shapes the design of our world is to click around the hundreds of stories about design that are reported in the way that, you know, only we really do.
我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 电台的一个项目，节目制作于 Arxine 的办公室。Arxine 目前正在寻找几位简历上有5到15年经验的新建筑师，欢迎在 Arxine.com 投递简历来参与设计，你也可以在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心工作。你可以在 Facebook 上查找并给本节目点赞，也可以在 Twitter 和 Instagram 上关注我们。但探索塑造我们世界设计的“99%无形”活动的最佳方式，是点击浏览数百篇关于设计的报道，它们以那种你知道只有我们才能真正做到的独特方式呈现。
And 99pr.org Radio Tepia From PRX Radio Tapio from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
99pr.org。来自 PRX 的广播电台。来自 PRX 的广播电台。本集节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。